[Música]
hola hoy quiero invitarlos a reflexionar
a reflexionar sobre este mundo que
cohabitamos un mundo que se está
transformando se está transformando de
una manera muy rápida en la cual los
paradigmas que conocemos están cambiando
un mundo en el cual por momentos
sentimos de que todo es instantáneo todo
está al alcance de un clic al alcance de
un clic podemos conocer a alguien al
alcance de un clic podemos comprar un
seguro al alcance de un clic tenemos
acceso a nuestra cuenta bancaria o al
alcance de un clic podemos solicitar un
diagnóstico pero ese mismo clic puede
llevarnos a un punto de quiebre puede
exponernos en las redes sociales o
quizás puede vaciar nos los ahorros que
con mucho esfuerzo generamos en toda la
vida bienvenidos a la transformación
digital la transformación digital es un
proceso es una ola perfecta que se ha
venido gestando por más de 20 años
una ola que lentamente fue tomando forma
basada en tecnologías disruptoras y que
en los últimos tiempos la causa del cobi
nos vimos inmersos en ella y quien nos
ha sentido incómodo con esta ola que ha
afectado a gobiernos dejando obsoletas
regulaciones a las empresas que se ven
obligadas a adaptar sus modelos de
negocio y a todos nosotros que no
entendemos que está pasando de un día
para otro nos vimos obligados a meternos
en un mundo virtual en un mundo en el
cual de repente nos encontramos
trabajando en casa
con nuestros chicos alrededor con todo
un contexto al que no estábamos
acostumbrados
pero hoy ya somos expertos manejando el
zoom
estamos ante una disrupción
una disrupción que no es un concepto
nuevo es algo que viene acompañando al
hombre desde que empezó a evolucionar en
la sociedad podemos hablar de disrupción
desde que empezamos a manejar las
primeras herramientas
generando así una capacidad diferente
basado en innovar en crear pero voy a
referir a cuatro grandes disrupciones lo
que se llama la primera revolución
industrial la segunda y la tercera que
al menos esas eran las que yo conocía
hasta el día de hoy
pero yo estoy hablando de una cuarta la
de la disrupción
digital de un concepto que me interesa
que les quede bien claro el concepto de
que en toda disrupción se produce un
escalón un escalón que algunos logran
subir y que otros al no lograrlo quedan
por el camino una disrupción que en
general se basa en innovación en
conocimiento y que aquellos que son
capaces de adoptar ese valor diferencial
logran que sus empresas tengan un factor
de producción mucho mayor al resto esto
ha sido una constante en la primera
revolución industrial con el vapor en la
segunda con la electricidad y el
desarrollo de los procesos en masa en la
tercera a través de la informática las
telecomunicaciones
un mundo global pero ahora llegamos a
una cuarta una disrupción digital basada
en datos
basada en tecnología más basada en la
convergencia de lo biológico con lo
informático y con la automatización
un contexto que nos expone a una
realidad de cambio nunca vista un
contexto en el cual aparecen nuevos
líderes como estos que estamos viendo
acá nuevos líderes entre los cuales si
ustedes observan
no van a ver a empresas como eso o
general electric
basadas en el paradigma del petróleo
basadas en conceptos que hoy son
obsoletos en su lugar aparecen nuevos
actores que todos ustedes los tienen en
la palma de la mano nuevos actores que
se basan en tecnologías disruptivas que
se basan en internet en lo que se llama
la nube que se basan en el procesamiento
masivo de datos
en inteligencia artificial
en algo que se internet de las cosas
máquinas que hablan con máquinas que hoy
son mucho más que las personas que
hablan entre personas un mundo en el
cual los datos son el nuevo petróleo un
mundo en el cual las startups
luchan contra lo que se llaman los
incumbentes empresas que tienen 100
50 30 años en el mercado y que de
repente
basado en un nuevo paradigma de la
cuarta disrupción digital
aparecen en el mercado nuevas propuestas
basadas en plataformas
que de alguna manera pero si sale esa
información y dejan obsoletas
las distintas empresas que integraban la
lista de s p500 por ejemplo y todos
estas emergen y en ese contexto de
disrupción de cambio podemos llegar a
maravillarnos
esta disrupción como que tiene dos caras
una cara en la cual podemos ver
maravillas como estas podemos ver autos
eléctricos que no contaminan que se
manejan solos bajando el número de
accidentes o máquinas que logran
realizar hazañas que eran increíbles que
puedan ser realizadas por computadoras
por robots quizás solo en ciencia
ficción pero un día una de estas
inteligencias artificiales
venció al campeón mundial el gran
maestro de ajedrez cascarón
y ese día descubrimos que estas máquinas
que parecen ser inteligentes son capaces
de desarrollar procesos que no nos
imaginábamos
la revolución que se produjo en el agro
y que nos está llegando por estos lados
y que está mejorando los factores de
productividad a través de tecnologías de
presión basada en satélites en
georeferencias
y cada una de estas máquinas va
conquistando terreno con sus datos con
su inteligencia con su capacidad de
procesamiento y que decir y cómo no
maravillarse
de la aplicación de las tecnologías
disruptivas en la medicina cuando
encontramos sistemas como watson que son
capaces de diagnosticar un cáncer de
piel con mayor presión de la que tiene
un médico humano cuando vemos todas
estas cosas no paramos de sorprendernos
debe de maravillarnos por el poder de
esta destrucción digital
girando el punto time que nos parecemos
cada vez más a dios es que vamos
modelando nuestro adn somos capaces de
editar el genoma y ustedes ya lo están
viendo con estas vacunas que a través de
la rm mensajero son capaces de generar
defensas en todos ustedes para luchar
contra esta pandemia que nos está
asolando y que nos hizo meternos en este
mundo digital y yo me puedo olvidar de
hablar
de estos nuevos mundos virtuales
quizás alguno escucho de los metaversos
mundos inmersivos de realidad virtual
donde esa promesa de juventud eterna esa
promesa de la belleza perfecta
parece hacerse realidad esta es una de
las caras de la transformación digital
que todos ustedes están viviendo
pero existe otra existe otra cada es
quizás la más visible sea la cara que
tiene que ver con el desempleo con la
sustitución de mano de obra por esas
máquinas que son capaces de llegar al
agro y trabajar de manera independiente
reemplazando la potencia del músculo
humano por la capacidad y la
inteligencia de una máquina que es capaz
de hacerlo mejor más rápido más preciso
pero esto es sólo la punta del iceberg
esto es lo que más se habla
recuerdan cuando racing salió diciendo
el fin del trabajo
un libro que nos conmocionó a todos los
que fuimos capaces de mirar ahora bien
esto es una mentira no se va a terminar
el trabajo
lo que pasa es que se transforma se
transforma y aquellos puestos como los
choferes de esas máquinas o de
ambulancias o de colectivos y antes de
repente tenían con muy poca capacitación
una oportunidad de inserción laboral
ahora deberían estar manejando drones
que vuelan solos o metiéndose sistemas
en archivos como estos metaversos para
realizar transacciones digitales o
porque no ser relatores de los y sports
se dan cuenta que lo que cambia es que
se requieren nuevas habilidades
nuevas capacidades que les permitan
insertarse en este mundo digital pero
ahí está la paradoja la paradoja está en
la palabra
reconversión laboral que todos
escuchamos saben porque es una paradoja
porque el ritmo de cambio que estamos
viviendo es un ritmo exponencial
es un ritmo que el cerebro humano no es
capaz de procesar y que lo que termina
pasando
es que nuestra capacidad lineal de
absorber esos cambios va dejando mucha
gente por el camino
y esa gente
comienza a ser prescindibles
comienza a parecer una nueva casta una
nueva casta como dice usual hararé de
personas que ya no van a poder reclamar
por mejores condiciones laborales y ya
no van a poder reclamar por un aumento
de salario porque van a ser
prescindibles y esas personas que van y
tirando por el camino para tener que
encontrar quizás en los metaversos
un espacio donde llenarse donde
conectarse a ese mundo de felicidad
inmediata
un espacio que hoy ustedes ya están
viendo en la palma de su mano por
ejemplo cuando ingresan a instagram
tictoc y ahí vemos
una generación totalmente conectada
todos ustedes tienen su paradigma en la
mano o sea son nuevos en más y otros
menos pero algunos de ustedes hoy han
desarrollado una adicción hacia este
tipo de redes hacia este tipo de mundos
en los cuales ya no me sacó una foto sin
tener un filtro
ya no me saco un vídeo si te pueda
evitarlo para que todos digan que joven
soy que perfecto y en este mundo de
filtros de realidades de separación de
ese mundo real y el mundo virtual lo que
vemos es cada vez gente más sola cada
vez gente más triste más deprimida y ni
que hablar en este momento de pandemia
donde nos llevaron a las cavernas
pero todas estas tecnologías
refuerzan este comportamiento y poco a
poco vamos entregando vamos entregando
nos que entregamos entregamos nuestros
datos nuestro comportamiento
nuestras ganas de conectarnos nuestras
ganas de pertenecer en un mundo que ha
dejado de ser transparente y que de
alguna manera este mundo cada vez más
nos expone y lo que parece ser termina
siendo otra cosa y al mismo tiempo es un
mundo en el cual esa línea de lo privado
empieza a desaparecer
y permanentemente nosotros sin querer o
porque estamos obligados aceptamos los
términos y condiciones de todas las
aplicaciones que se nos instalan en el
celular sin leer una línea cuando dice
que por poco si pudieran comprar nuestra
alma estaría sería propiedad de ellas
y así después nos extrañamos cuando
utilizando toda esta capacidad de esta
potencia aparecen las famosas noticias
falsas o face news que cuando impactan
en un político de turno o en una persona
famosa se arma un gran revuelo porque
alteró una campaña política porque logró
generar una sensación incorrecta de
determinado personaje público pero a mí
me preocupa mucho más qué pasa con esa
manipulación en cada uno de ustedes en
cada uno de nosotros una manipulación
que sin saberlo nos va llevando a
convertirnos en zombies en zombies
digitales zombies digitales que en la
medida que nos metemos en esta trama de
datos lo que comienza a suceder es que
nos convertimos en el producto cuando
nos creemos que somos en clientes
convirtiéndonos así en la energía que
mueve
este nuevo sistema digital estas son dos
caras esta es una cara y hace un rato
les presenté la de las oportunidades
pero hoy quiero centrarme en esta imagen
esta imagen de la transformación digital
que nos va encerrando en burbujas nos
van cerrando en lo que yo llamo una
cárcel digital en la cual las personas
que se sienten solas las personas que de
alguna forma pasan a ser prescindibles
encuentran un mundo de felicidad y de
fantasía
una plataforma que poco a poco saca lo
peor de esta transformación para
conocernos a partir de los datos
y tomando los distintos sesgos y
características de cada uno lograr que
nosotros como producto hagamos lo que
las plataformas necesitan es por eso que
hoy yo quiero presentarles un desafío y
este panorama gris que les acabo de
presentar convertirlo en oportunidad en
una oportunidad de volver a humanizar
esta transformación digital porque
porque las herramientas no son ni malas
ni buenas estas herramientas que estamos
viendo van a ir hacia al lado que cada
uno de nosotros sepamos darle es por eso
que hoy yo quiero invitarlos a pensar en
un propósito en el propósito de utilizar
estas herramientas
para agregar valor
y quizás le digan y cómo puedo hacer
esto y bueno lo primero es entender lo
que está pasando
entender de que hoy sin saberlo
estábamos siendo adictos y nadie nos
advierte entender que hoy nuestros datos
tienen un valor
entender que tenemos que empezar a
exigir derechos ciudadanos digitales con
respecto a la privacidad de datos con
respecto a qué procesamiento se hacen
con esos datos con respecto a la
privacidad de cada uno de nosotros hasta
donde los distintos árboles que nos van
a instalar van a ser capaces de predecir
nuestros comportamientos y sin que lo
sepamos guiarnos hackear los y tomar
decisiones por nosotros
entonces lo que yo quiero que les quede
claro es que esto es posible pero quiero
que en conjunto pensemos un nuevo
horizonte un nuevo desafío basado en
algo tan simple
cambiar nuestro comportamiento y acaso
elijamos
por ejemplo la dieta de la información
yo les pregunto a ustedes lo siguiente
ustedes utilizan siempre el mismo
buscador para entrar a internet bueno
ahí tienen un ejemplo están poniendo
toda su información en una única ventana
que siempre les muestra la realidad a
través de que a través de una sola
percepción si yo empiezo
deliberadamente y hagan la prueba al
salir de este texto a buscar en otras
herramientas de las que existen de
búsqueda para descubrir otras realidades
y es ahí cuando empezamos a liberarnos
de esas burbujas que no casualmente esos
algoritmos eligen que nos muestran
cuando demuestran actúa a ti algo al
otro le muestran algo diferente
por último pero no menos importante es
que cada uno de ustedes
empiece a optar pequeños comportamientos
a ver por ejemplo si cuando navega es
capaz de borrar esas cookies de utilizar
por ejemplo
una plataforma que me permita navegar de
incógnito y de esa forma
gradualmente yo me voy antes
conectando de esas burbujas que me
conocen y voy a empezar a absorber
información tinta que quizás no esté tan
manipulada entonces cuál es el verdadero
desafío lograr de que cada uno de
ustedes emprendedores tome lo bueno de
esas herramientas para que para hackear
este sistema de datos hoy nos manipula y
a partir de ahí que sean capaces de
romper el piloto automático de dejar de
pensar con un clic y empezar a pensar
con la cabeza con información distinta
para generar así un mundo de
transformación digital más humanizado
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]